tout ce qui s'est passé qu'ils ont été
justes à l'elysée matignon rabat un
pardon mais s'il ya sur le lac est
acheté réserver le court numéro 4 de
tennis à celle de la terre battue tu vas
kiffer je dois je ne vous ai pas oublié
les mecs connaît ça doit les émissions
avions jusqu'au bout de la nuit
cemex est alors c'est bon alors oui
alors si j'arrive à en placer une
alors qu'elle s'est passé avec édouard
finit donc on a on attend ça va vous
arriver à matignon donc à comment ça se
passe on arrive à matignon sonne déjà il
ya un interphone non mais non mais mon
envie de savoir mais je suis jamais allé
non mais ils nous attendaient devant la
porte se massant encore pu clos attendu
mais oui parce qu'ils n'ont pas rentré
deux minutes nous attend si si si vous
voulez exactement le coup les voilà on
s'est présenté au culot à 4h30 on a dit
voilà on n'a pas de nouvelles on a on
avait envoyé un peu comme quoi le
rendez-vous qu'on nous a empêché mardi
on a voulu la voir aujourd'hui hier soir
on s'est tous téléphoner on a dit bah on
va y aller au culot quoi donc vous êtes
allés devant matinée mais comme on n'a
rien on matin je termine les scores
chéri d'accord c'est beau et donc on
s'est pointé à 4h30 on a dit voilà on
avait un rendez-vous mardi mon nez
vendredi mon bien quand même d'accord
donc évidemment sur des sur des la
sécurité parce que l'élysée cet après
midi à envoyer un communiqué de presse a
répondu en disant que le président de la
république ne souhaitait pas recevoir
les gilet jaune
en tout cas les et engage les citoyens
engagés qui se sont portés volontaires
mais que la porte de matignon reste est
ouvert
donc voilà pourquoi la porte était
restée ouverte contacts clients
n'arrivent
arrive évidemment sur la garde ils
prennent nos identités un truc des
chocolats qui n'ont rien du tout at on
attendu dehors temps quatre heures très
bien voilà au bout il ne pouvait pas
nous recevoir parce qu'il y avait
réunion de crise
bah oui il y avait il ya vait mounir oui
donc non union qui suit mounir m bruit
on était à 4h30 en réunion avec près de
la moitié du gouvernement à discuter
mais arrêtez vous appelez ça une crise a
lancé laissez moi aller jusqu'au bout je
voulais expliquer tout est là on était
avec mes collègues avec le premier
ministre a discuté ensemble de puisqu'on
a fait l'annoncé ce qu'on a pris cet
engagement et cette prise de conscience
collectif sur le quart nord-ouest mais
chad et à la sueur sans les expliquer je
peux le faire aussi mais c'est j'aurais
l'air plus con donc et on a fait
l'annoncé qu'on allait de façon
définitive à long terme faire de notre
démocratie une démocratie qui écoutent
plus et qui inclut plus les citoyens et
premier ministre il a démarré la réunion
disant oh bah maintenant vous avez tous
bossé là dessus ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire quoi impliquer les citoyens
plus régulièrement dans la définition
des sujets les plus importants pour eux
comment on fait entendre les voix qu'on
entend jamais comment on impliqué
députés pour être vraiment dans le
diagnostic local territoriale
millimétriques chaque rue dans chaque
quartier pour vraiment de réunions crise
et donc et répondre ensemble
structurellement à aquaval cette grande
consultation alors pour définir ensemble
en six mois on a bossé et vous étiez en
train d'arriver ce soir m6 d'état et je
vous ai entendu avec monsieur secrétaire
d'état donc là vous êtes en train de
travailler là ça sonne et attend
quelqu'un est là et a donc là le premier
ministre et à bastien il voulait faire
assez inquiète pas facile car avec toi
donc la jac une excision donc voilà une
fois que nos identités ont été sans même
vérifier leur malaise cyril personne ne
pourra me réanimer là je suis le seul
médecin non merci
jacqueline c'est bon c'est sa cuve de
mazout on nous fait donc rentré on nous
dit que c'était pour 8h30 finalement à
8h15
d'accord on nous fait rentrer ouais donc
évidemment il ya tout un tas de
protocole si vous n'y voyez là nous
sommes rentrés donc dans le temps
matignon on nous emmène dans l'entrée on
étende par le par le porche façon
d'aller ensuite on s'installe à la table
il est arrive et elle va le dire mais
c'était une table en merisier massif et
il est arrivé environ 10 minutes
il est arrivé environ dix minutes après
qu'on soit dans l'entrée on nous a
confisqué nos portables
d'accord voilà donc et on s'est assis à
la table et nous avons parlé de toutes
les revendications que tous les jaunes
ont qu'on a reçues de tous les deux tout
les gilets jaunes il répond que ce qu'on
entend il a répondu quoi donc
il a alors il a reconnu des erreurs oui
il a dit évidemment qu'il a rien à nous
mettre sur la table là ce soir jeudi à
trois gains mais conduiront la réalité
aurait donc à rien il a quand même est
attelée ces mois terminés avant déconner
non plus il a reconnu qu' il savait que
le malaise des français existait mais
que depuis longtemps et que c'est bien
plus profond que le pouvoir d'achat
parce que le malaise des français
aujourd'hui c'est un malaise de
reconnaissance de la coopération et de
considération accord donc voilà donc ce
qui va ou pas ce qu'il va prendre votre
malaise et d'autres malaises y va tous
les coiffeurs t il va ramener tout ça à
monsieur macron et moi pour qui la prise
de notes
ah oui oui l'a privé d'un talent de
costumes il ya plus détaillée avec son
secrétaire met d'accord et est donc et
donc il va ramener tout ça monsieur
mâcon et pour moi la fin du mouvement
c'est monsieur macro qui a la clé de
l'accord du mouvement à corps et le
mouvement s'arrêtera ou continuera donc
monsieur macron parlera alors c'est
mounir est ce que monsieur mac os que le
président merci bravo jacques pin
à la merci la russie alors ouais c'est
les mecs ils applaudissent on dirait
qu'elle a trouvé un mot dans des
chiffres et des lettres